F I see you you're closing in on the
terminal I'll work on a way to get you
across to the second one once you're
[Music]
done there isn't much cover in there so
the trick will be to stay on the move
their tracking algorithm isn't all that
good if don't stop we retargeting you
and you should be okay and there should
be as few places where they can but for
a
breather
go fast and they can't track
you run B you can do it we're about to
Spring the Ambush I want both movs clear
you understand yeah we're doing our best
here I don't need your best I just need
it
[Music]
done Ambush sprung team Anders move in
team burner dead flank to the
left Target spotted leading an enforcer
Squad take them
out forces down pursue the
target
I said subdue
[Music]
her Target in the bag All Team stand by
to
extract yeah well done head for the roof
I got a ride waiting for
you con set reinforcements approaching
what's the stat in a almost done almost
won't cut it
all right it's tight while I get this
moving jump to
it hang on while I turn this
thing if you ever Tire of being a runner
you could always become a crane operator
Icarus